all right joining us now he is the host
of crtv's levin tv the host of life
liberty and levin
wow you had big ratings this weekend
right here on the fox news channel
i call him the great one mark levin uh
we missed you a couple of weeks
and we're glad you're back my friend
let's talk the election thank you
well you know what it's time uh for we
the people to stand up
for ourselves for our families for our
faith
for our country for our party and for
our president you know the media
have interposed themselves in this
election sean
we're actually fighting the media we're
fighting the democrats for fighting
academia we're fighting hollywood and
all the rest
and 64 of the voters say the press has
done more to divide
the country more people think the press
has divided the country than the
president the united states and i'm
going to tell you why the word hitler is
very popular with the press with joe
scarborough
the word white supremacy is very popular
over there at cnn the word stalin's now
starting to pick up
they consider those of us who support
this president and support an
america agenda as nazis they referred to
us to
as a racists as white supremacists
every time there's some horrific event
they try and pin it on us pin it on our
president
pin it on our party it's really time
america to push back
enough is enough we cannot turn
any part of this government over to
these radical
hardcore democrats and their mouthpieces
in the media and i want to give you a
few examples here
they talk about the president his tone
and the relationship the violence the
president hasn't caused any violence
when antifa is out there beating up
people the marxist militia
the media very passive rarely say
anything
when bill clinton pardoned the fallen
terrorists
who murdered murdered four people and
injured 44 other people
i don't remember them saying bill
clinton was contributing to a violent
tone in this country
when barack obama commuted the leader of
that organization
who never repented i don't remember them
bringing that up
when barack obama befriended bill ayers
and bernadine dorn
of the weather underground and the sds
the bombers domestic terrorists
i don't remember anybody talking about
him and violence and the tone of
violence do you
obama opens a embassy in cuba
a genocidal police state he's celebrated
donald trump moves our embassy from tel
aviv to jerusalem the capital of israel
and he's attacked by fools like steve
schmidt over on msnbc
now let's talk about immigration briefly
dwight eisenhower he's not considered a
white supremacist
is he he's not considered a racist is he
dwight eisenhower when he became
president of the united states
he created a program called operation
[ __ ]
that's not me that was him operation
[ __ ] what was that
he ordered the military to round up 1.3
million illegal aliens
and deport them and that's exactly what
he did and he was supported by the
democrat party too
i'll go further 1960s cesar chavez the
founder of the united
farm workers union he ordered his
members at night
to watch the southern border and report
illegal aliens coming over the border to
then the ins
1969 chavez ralph abernathy who'd been
the
confidant of martin luther king in 1969
and walter mondale i don't believe he
was a racist they led protests
on the southern border against illegal
immigration i'll go on
the press says donald trump is
threatening freedom of the press how so
by calling them out by challenging them
by exposing them
john adams one of our greatest founders
put in place the sedition act
the sedition act he actually put some
newspapers out of business and put some
journalists in prison
abraham lincoln put out an executive
order they shut down
almost 300 newspapers have put
journalists and editors in prison
and not not only that the great
progressive leader
woodrow wilson he had the sedition act
of 1918
did the same thing put some journalists
in prisons
and prison and some of his opponents
donald trump hasn't done
anything like this he's not rounding up
illegal immigrants
who are in this country by the hundreds
of thousands he's not
shutting down newspapers he's not
putting journalists in prison
yet they refer to him as hitler and as
stalin
and then we have this policy where we
separate children from their parents who
come here illegally
not because we want to put them in cages
like obama did
but because we want to protect these
children from coyotes
from kidnappers you got to sort them out
and figure out who's who since they're
here illegally
and they said well he's putting them in
internment camps actually
it was franklin roosevelt who actually
put japanese americans and americans
of japanese descent in internment camps
they don't call him hitler
they don't call him stalin or anything
of this sort and i'll even go here
they attack our president they say a
womanizer they bring the stormy daniels
in front of tv left and right left and
right
this president has been our president
he's conducted himself in the oval
office
with great acumen great acumen
oh people are laughing jfk was having
affairs constantly in the oval office in
the white house
with an east german spy with a mob boss
girlfriend with a 17 year old intern
and he was outdone by lbj we don't talk
about that stuff
how come because our goal you see is to
trash the president of the united states
the media in this country
america is campaigning against you
campaigning against your values
campaigning against your virtue
against the declaration against the
constitution and you have a rare
opportunity every now and then
to show yourself to stand up and say
we're not putting up with this anymore
we're going to protect our country we're
going to protect our values our
institutions our party
and our president and most of all
ourselves
you're sick of being called nazis you're
sick of being called racists
you're sick of being called white
supremacists then you need to vote
and you need to vote now if you have
early voting and you need to vote
tuesday
and you need to be your own precinct
captain to bring out four five six
people and make sure you vote
because here's the deal if more of us
vote
we win if less of them vote they lose
mark levitt um by the way i want to say
publicly our condolences
i knew your dad he recently passed away
a great man
thank you my friend being with us don't
miss it mark show big show this weekend
life liberty levin
didn't want to miss it sunday night
right here on the fox news channel